so today  i am going to go to a date with someone  and i'm  very hopeful that he will like me  hi eric hi larissa  how are you good how have you been  but a little bit lonely  eric is my ex-boyfriend my feeling for  etiquette is above all my relationship  and bigger thing i have  felt with coach i always was in love  with  ericky when we were dating but i decided  to break it up with  him because for all the kind of  relationship  problems and i thought that he don't  admire me anymore  but i miss being in a relationship with  him  because eric isn't perfect but he always  tries to help me out  when we are together and he doesn't  judge me for anything that i did in my  [Music]  life